hello everyone I'm a lot of welcome to
my channel this video is sponsored by
SiteLock we hear more from them later
but for the most part enjoy watching me
go from first game of the stream last
place last game of the stream first
place it was awesome
just so you guys know it's alright hey
warm up game babe I definitely took a
risk by getting you up here but I didn't
feel like it was gonna work no matter
what it's fine you know
first game whatever not a big deal
have you been in any of the vaults wait
no I know once no inside the trailer
it's like over there well they're just
like jumps off the cliff and teleports
into a little ball that's cool I ain't
got [ __ ] so maybe their gun would be
dope yeah there's definitely another
team here
it's a pathfinder without floor
well no I'm scared just two Spitfires
huh okay no no no thank you
well yet okay now you pick up yep
thank you no I'm just gonna throw that
out yeah I downed him well it's coming
to more what this is weird
suspicious I don't like it somebody's up
yeah
you just have to Spitfires yeah I'm
trying to get it's a safe spot it's the
worst loadout yeah I'll take the shotgun
let's do it that's better than having
two of the same why that's a lobe okay
she just shot me can you
[Applause]
one down now the third got me from this
side oh my god thank you you need it
I like the Mastiff felt all right to me
yeah tighter but that's what she says
okay I will take that I will take that
all the right besides oh so we can oh
yeah with my is take your time I need
something better than this okay
all I'm pretty good we got this digital
threat trying to think of who's best I'm
gonna take it because then I can tell
you guys at the very least so blue need
that I don't need any of this like this
is the first game in which I've actually
gotten the golden backpack which I feel
like it's kind of ideal for like flying
but there's like updates oh yeah yeah I
think I did yeah I'll give you this so
pres oh thank you basically like a
[ __ ] stacked lifeline right now like
good to heal we just need better amo
oh no okay okay you got poeple inflamed
we just need to get a you Asian I feel
bad calling you Asian but it's what you
know you named yourself that BAM I
didn't do that yeah I can call you
Toronto I do feel people's now to the
sponsored part of this video for anyone
who doesn't know site look is a high
speed VPN service it's great for people
who work from home use public internet
maybe doing school online as a normal
people are doing now because you're all
at risk of having a personal information
stolen site log VPN protects your
personal data things like passwords
banking info credit cards all very
important stuff from hackers advertisers
the government so you can safely browse
the Internet check your bank account our
online shop and obviously those are
things that we do sometimes without even
thinking about our security it's also
really easy to use check the link in my
description box to get site lock VPN
starting at only $9.99 per month there's
also no commitment so you can cancel at
any time and for a limited time use code
may 22 save 20% full life on your
subscription I don't like how open we
are everything feels suspicious this
whole time I've been playing the hole
all of my experience is playing season
five of felt very suspicious I'm like
mmm well the girl shucks where is
everyone
yeah they're in the corner over there
oh absolutely yeah quintal third party
game okay let's roll him if you see him
no I see him nice yeah squats yeah
you're right there
I'm not sure someone
take myself up probably should have let
you get in the room but it's fine
I got hasty okay I feel like we're in a
pretty good position with three squads
left see Dogbot Wow Wow hot name I have
my alt again but I don't know that we
want to do it right now
yeah actually should right now and at no
other point you guys cool if I drop it
yeah yeah we got a pretty defensible
position yeah it's coming I think
they're fighting in the caves should
probably sit we should question okay
you gotta check your thing for a shotgun
bolt though no I'm sad and shotgun well
sorry all right let's go ain't nothin
better than when you're on your way
oh boy wait have you already dropped two
of them over on out yeah I think there's
only one person we don't get ranked well
I'll be bait okay think he circled
around the market I mean what's the deal
on fam what's his plan it's coming back
in though okay we're not let's just get
in the zone for now yeah so we go from
asylum 3v1 it's pretty good sir yeah I
deserve this win I said I was gonna stop
playing at eight if I finish on a win my
nose let's go here I almost feel bad
it's like Cooper well who wants to take
it release anyone's
[ __ ] stupid ring I did not do this
efficiently here we go yeah we good I'm
good everything's fine
don't suck all right
yeah I'm gonna eat nice well it's time
to see you to building yeah I think so
along see oh she's giving up she's
giving up she's dropping everything oh
oh you can have fun oh that's so sad
though but what no I just feel bad drop
your drone I don't know if I
oh I don't wanna do that
I'm punching fight oh I just dropped
promise oh me okay yeah I can drop on my
almost there you go I hope we don't get
tricked here I don't think she has any
of her guns what's gonna throw a light
when you call it
I made the signal to start the fight but
why not we can rush it hits somebody say
we don't rush when it it's somewhat of
your house Duffek oh all right I gotta
get a hit in you know good punch in ah
landed it
the final punch that's a satisfying
champion I tell you amazing you are the
apex champion nice work you guys
nice work we did it
it's bad man what we did it right yeah
good stuff stop streaming but thank you
for you know helping me get my job I
still have never had a session where I
played this game with strangers who were
following me or whatever and not one at
least one which you know when you guys
are you know 300 ish it's very helpful
thank you for joining me friends
yes sir have a good night thank you so
you two litters bye